food delivery apps are a scam do you
want to get Chinese food ubereats do you
want to get Indian food ubereats do you
want to get burgers or Uber Eats do you
want to get pizza well maybe doordash
food delivery has become a ubiquitous
service that virtually everyone uses in
fact 86 of Americans use food delivery
at least once a month 31 use it at least
twice a week and ask for Millennials I
mean this is basically their entire diet
this is not too surprising given the
extraordinary convenience of these food
delivery acts you can order from
virtually any restaurant in your
vicinity and they have it delivered to
your doorstep within an hour this is in
stark contrast to food delivery just 10
years ago when your options were
basically just pizza this unprecedented
surge has allowed for the food delivery
industry to thrive with several apps
popping up from ubereats and doordash to
GrubHub and the postman
but while these apps sure are convenient
they're not exactly a great deal for
anyone the average American spends 37.28
every week on food delivery which
translates to 150 per month or over
eighteen hundred dollars per year and
over a third of that amount is simply
going towards service fees delivery fees
and tips coming in at 13 per order or
650 per year but I'm sure you already
knew that
for most people food delivery is more of
a guilty pleasure than anything but
unlike Netflix binging and singing in
your car this habit will cost you a lot
more in fact if young adults simply
invested food delivery money into the S
P 500 between the ages of 20 and 65.
they would end up with an extra 715
000 instead of a bunch of empty Panda
Express boxes but let's not just end the
consumers who are getting a bad bargain
either food delivery is also not that
great for restaurants delivery drivers
or even the food delivery apps
themselves yet the popularity of food
delivery is only continuing to Skyrocket
so here's why food delivery apps are
kind of a scam for everyone and why no
one seems to care anyway
we all know that food delivery is
expensive but just how expensive it is
it well let's do the math single adults
tend to spend between 59 and 91 every
week at the grocery store so about an
average of 75 dollars per week There's
No stats about how much single adults
spend on food delivery but we do know
how much gen zero spend on food delivery
which should be pretty close the average
gen zero spends about 30 dollars per
food delivery order so even ordering
food delivery just once a week would
increase the average person's food
budget by almost 50 percent twice a week
would increase the budget by 80 percent
and three times a week would increase
the budget by a hundred and twenty
percent for those of you who use food
delivery every day I know you're
watching you're increasing your food
budget by nearly 300 spending 210
dollars every week on food delivery on
the bright side your grocery bill is
probably probably far lower than average
but that's not exactly a net positive to
make things worse this shortfall will
only compounded throughout your life
just one food delivery per week will set
your retirement back six hundred
thousand dollars obviously assuming that
you invest your money well instead this
means that two deliveries per week is
costing you 1.2 million three deliveries
is costing you 1.8 million and a
delivery every day is costing you 4.2
million dollars at that point pack could
it literally be your entire retirement
the only way that this is not a bad
financial decision is if you're already
investing a hundred thousand dollars or
more every year at that rate you'd be
worth 40 million by the time you're 65
so 4.2 million would still be a large
amount but percentage-wise it's not
terrible I suspect that most of you
aren't investing a hundred thousand
dollars every year though so probably
best to cut back on the food delivery
now I know what some of you are are
already saying what's the point of
having so much money at retirement if
you didn't even get to enjoy the journey
there and that is valid 74 of people say
that they would show up to an event if
they knew the food was going to be good
so there's no doubt that food plays a
big role in people's lives this brings
us to exhibit B though which is how much
money is going towards the food itself
and how much is going towards delivering
it may seem like you're just paying a
delivery fee and a tip but that's just
what's shown you see it restaurants know
that people are willing to pay more for
the same food when it's offered for
delivery and they've taken the Liberty
to increase prices across the board on
delivery apps take Panda Express for
example a family feast costs 39 at the
restaurant but it costs between 45 and
47 on delivery apps it might not seem
like a big difference but when you
combine this with the delivery fees and
service fees it becomes quite egregious
the same Subway order cost 25 more on
GrubHub 46 more on doordash 63 more on
Postmates and 91 more on ubreads and
that's not even accounting for a tip on
average if people tipped 15.7 for food
deliveries so really if you're spending
an extra 40 to 100 over your meal price
just for the delivery let's call it an
average of 70 here's what this means
long term 247
000 of this is going to delivery 494 000
of this is going to delivery 741
000 of this is going to deliver it and a
disgusting 1.7 million dollars of this
is going to deliver it that's enough
money to make a grown man cry but all of
that is just the consumer side of things
[Music]
YouTube has very much glamorized the
life of delivery drivers trying to make
500 in a day trying to make 700 in a day
trying to make ten thousand dollars in a
month I mean there's nothing wrong with
these videos they're a fun entertaining
challenges but don't take them for
anything more than just that while
delivering food it may be lucrative for
broke college students and young adults
it's not exactly as good as it sounds
especially as a career to reach numbers
like ten thousand dollars per month
delivery drivers have to work 12 to 15
hours every single day and and when you
do the math it's not all that great even
calling it just 12 hours per day
delivery drivers have to work 360 hours
per month to reach those numbers if
delivery drivers worked a more
reasonable 40 hours per week or 160
hours per month they'd make about 53 000
per year which doesn't sound too bad but
that number is actually super misleading
because most of us contextualize that
number as a job I mean that's how much
teachers and police officers make but
the difference between making 53 000 on
new breeds and making 53 000 on a job is
Day first of all the job is infinitely
more stable but let's put that aside as
there's plenty of other attributes to
discuss for example most of the numbers
you see on YouTube are top line numbers
that don't account for gas or
depreciation of the car but let's even
put that aside the real first obstacle
that you'll face as a delivery driver is
taxes as a delivery driver your tax
status will be self-employed which means
that you have have to pay both sides of
Social Security and Medicare tax this
adds up to an extra 7.65 to every single
year so earning 53 000 on ubereats is
effectively the same as earning 49 000
at a job and that's just because of
taxes next you have to deal with health
insurance most people are making forty
nine thousand dollars per year have some
sort of government job or low end
private job either way though the
benefits are pretty strong in most cases
the average teacher for example gets ten
thousand five hundred dollars in health
insurance benefits as a delivery driver
you'll have to pay this amount out of
pocket which takes your salary down to
thirty eight thousand five hundred
dollars after that we have retirement
benefits police officers for example get
as much as twenty nine thousand dollars
towards retirement every year if you're
trying to match this as a delivery
driver you'll be down to less than ten
thousand dollars in that income but we
can be more conservative let's say
you're missing out on five thousand
dollars in retirement benefits that
still knocks you down to 30 three
thousand five hundred dollars most jobs
will also have paid time off sick days
and other perks but if you want these as
a delivery driver you'll have to pay it
out of pocket which will bring your net
income to below 30 000 but it gets even
worse when you hear that police officers
and teachers make fifty or sixty
thousand dollars that's truly an average
Across the Nation these jobs exist in
every community and every city across
the world really the opportunity to do
ubreads full-time however only exists in
the highest cost of living cities like
New York San Francisco London Austin Etc
I mean you're not gonna be very busy if
you're trying to do ubereats in Nebraska
in many of these High Cost of Living
cities the minimum wage itself is 15 per
hour which translates to just over
thirty thousand dollars per year so
while Topline numbers on YouTube
challenges may look appealing driving
for these food delivery apps is
basically just an unstable minimum wage
job
it's not just consumers and the drivers
that are getting screwed over by these
apps either restaurants are also getting
the short end of the stick have you ever
wondered why delivery prices are
relatively affordable of course we've
discussed how even these small 10 to 15
fees can add up over time but in terms
of face value it's not too big of a fee
to have any restaurant delivered to your
doorstep well the reason for this is
that you're not the only one that's
paying restaurants have to pay
exorbitant amounts to be listed on these
food delivery apps which was basically
required during the pandemic on doordash
for example restaurants have to pay 15
25 or 30 percent depending on how much
they want doordash to push their
restaurant doordash also gets an
additional six percent commission on
pickup orders given that they can't
charge you a delivery fee ubereats and
all of the other delivery apps are
virtually identical pricing plants and
given that restaurants tend to have
pretty meager profit margins of three to
five percent there's no question that
these fees weigh down on these
businesses quite a bit this is the main
reason that restaurants mark up their
food so heavily on these delivery apps
in the first place oftentimes they have
to charge it that much more just to
break even they also have no option to
avoid these apps either because the
pandemic transitioned much of their
customer base to delivery but delivery
apps aren't just hurting the bottom line
of restaurants they're also oftentimes
hurting their reputation you see it
first these delivery apps use extremely
aggressive sales people to convince
restaurant owners to lift their
restaurants but if they don't agree to
do it voluntarily these apps often just
to go ahead and list restaurants anyway
they figured that most owners don't have
the time money or energy to take these
corporations to court maybe one in a
thousand or one in ten thousand will
actually Sue and win but this doesn't
really matter for these apps they're
basically having to pay 300 or 500 000
for every 10
000 restaurants that they list so
listing these restaurants without the
owner's permission is a no-brainer net
positive the same however cannot be said
for owners when these apps list menus
without their permission they often end
up using outdated menus and prices so
customers end up ordering something and
to get mad when they realize that their
food is no longer being offered or cost
more than they thought customers will
naturally get mad at the restaurant and
think why don't these people even keep
their menus up to date but in reality it
wasn't even the restaurant's fault these
frustrations don't just apply to
wrongfully listed restaurants either
correctly listed restaurants have their
own set of headaches with the delivery
drivers and angry customers for example
drivers have the ability to drop an
order up until they pick it up and this
happens more often than you think the
driver arrives at the store and sees
that the line is super long or they find
a more lucrative delivery or whatever
the reason may be if another driver
doesn't accept to do the delivery the
food is ready and the customers want the
food but the food will never get to the
customer the customer will want to
refund it and the restaurant will have
lost out on the food and the money
little to say there's not much for
restaurants to get excited about when it
comes to food delivery apps
with customers getting screwed over
drivers getting screwed over and
restaurants getting screwed over you
would think that at least the food
delivery apps must be coming out on top
but this is also not the case all food
delivery apps lose money and the most
popular one to lose the most money
inflation is only making these losses
even worse with most delivery apps
posting record losses in the last 12
months doordash lost a record
1.36 billion dollars but that's nothing
in comparison to Uber's 9.1 billion loss
for Uber this isn't even a record as
they've been casually losing 8 to 10
billion dollars for four years now with
all the fees they charge everyone this
might be a bit confusing but when you
think about it it all makes sense the
only food industry it has Master
delivery and is able to stay profitable
is pizza chains and they have to make a
lot of sacrifices to achieve this every
restaurant only delivers to a very small
radius they have full-time delivery
drivers and they refine the delivery
process to be extremely efficient over
Decades of doing this modern delivery
apps are basically the exact opposite of
this drivers usually have to go to
different restaurants for each delivery
they have to deliver to a very big
radius and the drivers generally choose
deliveries based on how lucrative they
are as opposed to how efficient they are
for the overall platform given this
combination it's no wonder why delivery
apps are struggling to turn a profit the
bottom line is that delivering from any
restaurant to any doorstep is simply a
logistical nightmare that requires a
bunch of man hours would just not cost
effective by any means and never will be
in the meantime everyone from drivers
and consumers to restaurants and
delivery apps will have to put up with
the associated expenses and to think
that all of this pain for everyone can
be traced back to us being too lazy not
just to cook but even pick up cooked
food how often do you use food delivery
apps comment that down below also drop a
like if this video made you look at food
delivery differently and of course
consider checking out our Discord
community so just for the video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions at logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one